but i'm telling you after sons was over
shortly thereafter a couple years later
there was a series called bad blood yes
people love better blood yeah it was a
huge hit on netflix and rogers and and
city up in city tv up in canada and
to be called in on that and to be number
one on the call sheet
and to hire anthony lapaglia who's a
buddy of mine of paul cervino
these guys did it for a lot less money
than they normally get but the scripts
were so unbelievable based on the true
story
anthony played vito rizzuto a real crime
boss one of the biggest crime bosses in
the world let alone just canada from
montreal so he's playing a real guy
i played a fictional guy even though
between you and me now that it's over
he was based on a real guy who's um he's
still incarcerated so we couldn't
we couldn't really talk about him too
much but right and we had to change his
name his ethnicity the whole thing but
i'm telling you to be number one on the
call sheet and then after it was over to
have the actors and the actresses and
and producers just come up and go hey
man
way to go you you you really uh
you really did number one you really did
and i i did i cared about everybody and
i did the best i could in and making
everything comfortable but when it was
time to work
we [ __ ] worked man there's no there's
no dipsy doodling this is really serious
do you stress do you get anxiety do you
put pressure on yourself that's not
that is unnecessary do you uh fight
through things do you do how do you deal
with all that stuff or you just mr t
question it's a great question i i
didn't know but i'm i'm full of anxiety
i mean i i i have a strength that i see
once in a while and he's amazing he's in
pasadena and he really he calls me he
called me early in our sessions he would
call me
king kong
no because i [ __ ] bursted in the room
i'd never been to a shrink before in my
life
and i burst into new zealand paying out
i pay now where do i sit what do i how
are you today
he just you just kind of put his hand at
a small smile can you sit wherever you
want and we'll worry about the payment
later so you want it now in a check
check check like normally
a guy
you want this now we're going to keep
this a secret you want us now to keep it
straight you and me does it go anywhere
oh my [ __ ] being miked no no so
you